vous vous étiez dans le xviie
arrondissement de paris vous avez marché
avec les gilets jaunes diaries sont donc
place de la république pour rejoindre le
traditionnel décider du premier miss
effectivement amira ça a commencé dans
les alentours de 10 heures du matin dans
dix septième arrondissement donné rendez
vous au gilet jaune rendez vous a été
donné n'a pas au gilet jolie sont venus
progressivement pour une manifestation
qui a commencé dans les alentours de 11h
quadrillée par les forces de l'ordre un
important dispositif de sécurité a été
mis en place gendarmerie crs mais encore
police nationale le cortège a été fait
dans le calme à part quelques
débordements ou certains j'ai je l'avais
quittée est la manifestation la police a
fait usage de bombes lacrymogènes on a
senti quand même une des forces de
l'ordre qui n'est qui a été dépassée
complètement par les manifestants le
cortège avait repris dans nos environs
de midi c'était vers la place de clichy
pour se retrouver ici avec de nombreux
manifestants sur cette tâche de la
république qui est noir de monde en ce
1er mai je suis avec et stéphane et
esbly qui est un des gilles et jo merci
de répondre à nos questions alors
expliquez nous pourquoi c'est important
pour les jets jaune d'être présent ce
1er mai comme toutes les manifestations
et on n'a pas arrêté tous les samedis
donc toujours eu des manifestations
déclarées en préfecture pour revendiquer
ce qu'on demande depuis deux ans a pas
changé donc plus de justice et le mot
j'essaie de faire passer ces justice
tout court en fait c'est la justice
ce lundi je passe au tribunal j'ai
quatre amendes que je conteste et donc
beaucoup de gilet jaune ont reçu des
amendes fall est contestée dans les 45
jours et après on va jusqu'au tribunal
faut contester et précisé qu on est en
résidence à l'oppression l'oppression
est qualifié en france l'onu le
parlement européen donc à préciser de
qui avait une discrimination sol et
gilet jaune et donc maintenant la
manifestation c'est une chose la
deuxième phase je dirais c'est de
contester devant les tribunaux aller à
la barre moi je diffuse sur eux explique
point eu par exemple mon site
vous avez aimé mes notes de défense des
gens pour sont inspirés déposées çà en
écrit auprès au juge ou au procureur est
donc arrivé à se défendre devant les
tribunaux et j'irai panache en phase iii
personnellement et j'incite les gens à
le faire il ya les élections
départementales et des élections
régionales
eh bien on peut éventuellement se
présenter dans un canton est un canton
faut avoir donc cinq personnes un binôme
hommes-femmes des remplaçants et un
mandataire financier et on peut se
présenter aux élections faut essayer de
prendre reprendre le pouvoir par les
urnes même si ça sera très compliqué
mais c'est une façon d'y et d'y aller
avec un petit budget de 1000 euros on
peut faire des choses intéressantes qui
ressort des circulaires dans les boîtes
aux lettres de toute toute la
circulation et revendications des gilets
jaunes ont changé depuis maintenant deux
ans et demi notamment avec les
restrictions qui sont dues au cours d'un
virus est ce que vous en tant que gilet
jaune avec l'ensemble des jaunes des
revendications nouvelles et ont émergé
on n'est pas il faut il faut construire
maintenant donc il faut voir il faut
s'adapter par rapport à l'oppression que
l'on a en face de nous et donc pas je
vous parlais des élections je vous
parlais également dans que du tribunal
il faut oser faire ça il faut changer le
mode opératoire je dirais moi j'étais
déclarant pendant des manifestations n'a
que 14 et 15 c'est moi qui définit aux
préfectures l'été parcours mais après je
suis passé à un stade supérieur je dirai
tout activistes de terrain pour aller au
plus proche du pouvoir pour montrer la
colère populaire parce que tu as fait
donc notamment le préfet l'allemand il
nous renvoie dans des lieux on n'a pas
de visibilité ou ça ne dérange pas le
pouvoir et donc en manifestation
n'arrive plus à déranger le pouvoir il
faut donc arriver
montrer cette colère populaire et donc
mais des actions moi j'ai barbouillé
pendant dépendance parlementaire je
revendique et je vais au procès je suis
en procès contre le couple macro qui m'a
fait un procès je suis aller perturber
un peu leurs vacances à brégançon avec
mon omar j'avais un homard sur la plage
brigitte macumba fait elle a déposé
plainte j'ai été aurait défendu par juan
branco voilà faut faire des actions
d'éclat de ce style pour montrer qu'elle
colère populaire c'est pas que dabou
faisait que l'on fait même si moi je
fais un peu en mode bouffon parce que ça
permet de dédramatiser la situation
la situation est très grave je me prends
pas au sérieux le j'ajuste sérieusement
ce que fait l'inversé des politicards
que l'on actuellement ils se prennent au
sérieux une agissent pas sérieusement et
écoule la france est bien merci beaucoup
stéphane alors vous l'aurez compris la
colère populaire qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui sous cette place de la
république à l'occasion de ces
manifestations du 1er mai beaucoup de
groupes beaucoup d'appels à manifester
ici aujourd'hui sur cette place
concernant les gilets jaunes certains
d'entre eux sont encore ici d'autres ont
repris la marche direction nation et
bien sûr nous allons aller suivre pour
ce cortège qui pas qui a commencé il ya
quelques instants et qui doit se diriger
sur nation